I'm a strong advocate for
the study of the humanities
and the social sciences because
I believe that it's a way
for students to come to
get outside their own skin
and to really understand a
world beyond themselves often
by being able to
look at the world
through other people's eyes
and that to me seems essential.
First of all, to work with other
people, but also to be able
to get perspective on
themselves and what might be a
of idea they'd rethink
or something they would
no longer take for granted
or something they'd need to more
fully explain and understand.
So that kind of study that
introduces students to habits
of mind, to judgment, to
perspectives beyond themselves,
I think are at the heart of what
it means to become educated.
To become a person who's more
than just your single self,
but is a person related to the
rest of the world and the rest
of the people in that world.